salut c'est Romain 2000 idées de culture
générale j'ai 2 petites choses
importantes à vous dire avant que la
vidéo ne commence première chose ne
regardez pas la vidéo comme ça avec du
pop-corn
[Musique]
si vous voulez retenir ce que vous allez
là pendant cette vidéo vous devez
prendre des notes les études sur la
mémorisation ne laisse aucune place au
doute ne pas prendre de note égale
oublié donc faites-moi plaisir ouvrez
une application comme google doc Wever
note est noté ce qui est essentiel pour
vous au fur et à mesure second chose que
je dois vous dire la vidéo vous allez
regarder est extraite de ma formation de
culture générale qui s'appelle culture
exprès c'est une formation qui permet
d'acquérir rapidement une bonne culture
générale sans se prendre la tête sans
avoir à lire ni à réfléchir elle couvre
tous les domaines de la culture générale
le permet de maîtriser les connaissances
d'essentiel sur l'histoire de l'humanité
sur l'histoire de France en économie en
sciences politiques en psychologie en
sciences en littérature en art en
religion et enfin en philosophie c'est
important la philo si ça vous intéresse
je t'ai dit un coup d'œil sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description de cette
vidéo voilà voilà je vous ai dit ce que
je voulais vous dire maintenant je vous
laisse regarder la vidéo concentrez-vous
préparer vous à prendre des notes et
puis n'hésitez pas à m'écrire dans les
commentaires et moi je vous dis à la
prochaine
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que l'économie l'économie est
la discipline reine de notre temps c'est
concept et ses sujets connaissent un
large succès dans le débat public les
journaux et les chaînes de télévision on
crée des rubriques spécifiques les
économistes exercent leur expertise dans
les médias dans l'administration dans
les partis politiques ou encore dans les
entreprises les idées économiques sont
désormais indispensable pour comprendre
le monde
l'économiste est celui qui est toujours
capable d'expliquer ex post pourquoi il
s'est une fois de plus tromper écrit
Bernard Maris
pour ma part j'aime beaucoup l'économie
mais je m'en méfie pourquoi parce que
notre société accorde une confiance
excessive mais semble-t-il à cette
discipline intellectuelle depuis que
j'ai étudié l'économie en école de
commerce je suis même personnellement
par la mathématisation de la discipline
c'est évolution trahi à mes yeux la
volonté de s'arroger l'autorité
intellectuelle des sciences dures je
trouve cependant les idées économique
intéressante et utile
dans cette leçon je vais répondre aux
questions suivantes comment définir
l'économie d'où vient l'économie
l'économie est-elle vraiment une science
quels sont les branches de l'économie
qui sont les économistes
comment définir l'économie
que signifie le mot économie le moi
d'abord un sens banal dans l'existence
individuelle le café est certes cher
chez Starbucks aux alentours de 5 € mais
sans privé c'est peut-être réaliser une
économie inutile au regard d'autres
enjeux financiers comme l'achat d'une
voiture ou dans un appartement une
économie et c'est donc une réduction
voir une absence de dépenses il n'y a
pas de petites économies dit l'adage
populaire
si ce n'est certes pas le sens de
l'adjectif dans l'expression culture
économique il y a déjà l'idée de
l'optimisation de la valeur d'ailleurs
on peut aussi économiser de manière
figurer le temps l'énergie les efforts
la volonté exetera mais le temps ce qui
vous intéresse c'est celui de l'économie
comme discipline intellectuelle
du point de vue de l'étymologie le terme
économie vient de la jonction des mot
grec Oikos la maison le domaine et Némo
administrer dans la Grèce antique un
écho et plus précisément une unité
d'habitation qui regroupe les parents et
les esclaves et de production agricole
ou artisanale et la gestion de cet
ensemble avec une importance
particulière à l'époque
l'économie ce serait donc
étymologiquement l'administration du
domaine mais l'unité de référence
peut-on être la ville le pays voir le
monde est la définition varie selon
l'ensemble considérer
dans le sens le plus global l'économie
et donc la création et la répartition de
la valeur dans un groupe humain il faut
encore distinguer deux dimensions dans
ma définition première dimensions le
processus même de création et de
répartition de la valeur
s dimension l'optimisation de ce
processus grâce à la réflexion en tant
que discipline intellectuelle l'économie
se définit donc par son but
optimiser la création et la répartition
de la valeur dans un groupe humain
certains mots reviennent souvent
lorsqu'on parle d'économie on est fait
la réflexion économique présuppose une
certaine manière de voir le monde c'est
pourquoi elle nous offre une batterie de
concept pour interpréter la réalité
quels sont les acteurs les plus
importants de l'économie elle identifie
tout d'abord certains acteurs les
ménages c'est-à-dire les personnes
partageant le même domicile les sociétés
non financières les entreprises les
sociétés financières les banques les
assurances exetera les administrations
publiques l'état les collectivités
locales les organismes de sécurité
sociale et cetera et enfin les acteurs
économiques situé à l'étranger
depuis le 20e siècle on distingue trois
grands secteurs de production le secteur
primaire toutes les activités de
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
l'agriculture la pêche les forêts les
mines ou les gisements ensuite le
secteur secondaire toutes les activités
de transformation des matières premières
les industrie manufacturière la
construction par exemple et enfin le
secteur tertiaire toutes les activités
de service marchand ou non marchand
chaque acteur a une certaine fonction et
dispose de certaines ressources par
exemple les ménages consomment des biens
et services grâce à leurs revenus
quelles sont les fonctions de l'économie
la réflexion économique et met en
évidence cinq grandes fonctions première
fonction la production c'est-à-dire la
création de la valeur deuxième fonction
la consommation c'est-à-dire à la
satisfaction d'un besoin d'un désir
grâce à la valeur produite généralement
un bien ou un service
3e fonction la répartition c'est-à-dire
l'affectation de la valeur aux acteurs
4e fonction l'épargne c'est-à-dire la
mise en réserve de la valeur 5e et
dernière fonction l'investissement
c'est-à-dire l'affectation de la valeur
dans le but d'engendrer un futur
surcroît de valeur
le but de l'économie n'est pas le
travail mais la consommation a écrit
Alfred Sauvy
l'homme est un animal qui fait des
affaires un chien ne change pas son
autre contre celui d'un autre a écrit
Sydney Smith
la valeur circule dans un groupe humain
grâce à la procédure de l'échange
celui-ci peut-être direct c'est le troc
ou indirecte par l'intermédiaire de la
monnaie il est particulièrement
favoriser en un lieu spécial le marché
c'est là qu'une offre de bien et service
rencontre une demande lorsque cette
rencontre fixe librement le prix du bien
ou du service on parle alors d'une
économie de marché
enfin le débat public se focalise sur
quelques paramètre la croissance est
l'augmentation de la valeur économique
produites dans un pays le PIB pendant
une certaine période le chômage est la
proportion de la population qui ne
travaille pas bien qu'elle soit en
capacité de travailler l'inflation est
là-haut générale et durable des pris le
pouvoir d'achat est la capacité d'un
ménage à acheter des biens et services
grâce à son revenu enfin la dette
publique et l'ensemble des engagements
financiers contractée par l'État
d'où vient l'économie pour répondre à
cette question il faut distinguer la
réflexion économique telle que nous la
connaissons au 21e siècle d'une part et
la pensée économique antérieur
à quand remonte la pensée économique on
peut probablement trouver des idées
économique depuis qu'on peut trouver des
idées c'est-à-dire depuis que les hommes
pensent la réalité et pour cause
l'économie est une dimension primordiale
de la vie quotidienne d'un groupe humain
quelle qu'en soit la taille le groupe
humain dispose de ressources dont tu il
doit faire le meilleur usage possible
peu de richesse ménager avec économie
valent mieux que de grands trésors mal
employé dit un proverbe oriental
historiquement c'est le développement du
commerce qui est stimulé la
conceptualisation des le quatrième
millénaire avant Jésus-Christ les
marchands de la civilisation
mésopotamienne mettre une terminologie
particulière pour penser leur activité
ils comprennent déjà la logique du
marché l'avantage de s'associer pour
partager le risque est la valeur de la
prudence dans les affaires on trouve
également une pensée économique dans les
ancienne civilisation chinoise et
indienne mais la réflexion sert cette
fois-ci l'action de l'État et non pas
des intérêts privés elle relève
globalement de la science politique du
point de vue intellectuel la pensée
économique aurait donc deux sources
première source l'administration des
affaires et s source la philosophie
politique
l'économie n'est donc pas une discipline
intellectuel en tant que tel d'un côté
et les hommes d'affaires certainement
très pragmatique approfondissent les
questions économiques pour s'enrichir et
puis de l'autre côté les philosophes et
les hommes d'État y réfléchisse avec une
plus grande ampleur de vue pour exercer
le pouvoir et pour atteindre débute -
prosaïque tel que l'harmonie sociale
quand l'économie prend-elle son visage
moderne l'économie telle que nous la
connaissons on est au 18e siècle cette
saisir s'explique par le décollage de la
croissance le monde a vécu jusque-là
dans une économie de pénurie marqué
parler disait de la répétition mais
comme on l'a vu dans la leçon sur la
révolution scientifique le revenu par
habitant d'école avec la révolution
industrielle au recette évolution et la
preuve que l'augmentation de la
population n'entraîne pas forcément un
appauvrissement systématique et qu'au
contraire elle peut stimuler la
croissance
ainsi sur le plan intellectuel c'est
l'idée de la croissance qui fait passer
la pensée économique à un niveau
supérieur à cette époque on parle
désormais d'économie politique
political economy en anglais pour
désigner la réflexion sur la création et
la répartition de la richesse dans un
pays l'idée s'impose alors que la
fortune de l'État dépend de la
prospérité de la nation
pauvre paysan pauvre royaume pauvre
royaume pauvre roi a dit François caisse
mais les hommes qui comme François même
ce genre de réflexion commence pas se
dire économiste il ne cherche plus
seulement apprécier des recettes ils
veulent désormais dans l'esprit de la
science moderne comprendre les
phénomènes économiques afin d'en déduire
des solutions
l'économie est-elle vraiment une science
la réponse des parents bien évidemment
de la définition de la science comme mon
but est simplement de vous donner une
vue d'ensemble du débat je ne vais pas
entrer dans les détails mais seulement
vous présenter les principaux arguments
quels sont les arguments pour
en premier lieu l'économie suis la
méthode de la science moderne elle
pratique le doute pour éviter le dôme
elle essaie de découvrir des lois elle
mais ces hypothèses à l'épreuve de
l'expérience et puis elle favorise le
débat dans une communauté de savants
à l'instar des physiciens les
économistes construisent leur théorie
avec la précision que permet l'usage des
mathématiques a dit Gregory Mankiw
hauteur d'un manuel de référence dans
les universités
ensuite et l'économie imite les sciences
dures les économistes académiquement
reconnu au 21e siècle raisonne comme des
physiciens ils ont adopté la même
démarche globale le même langage
mathématique et certains transpose même
carrément les nouveaux résultats de la
physique en économie une Fischer à par
exemple transférer les concepts de la
physique newtonienne
enfin l'économiste moderne fait un large
usage des statistiques grâce à la
puissance de calcul des ordinateurs il
récolte tel un expérimentateur de grande
quantité de données et les passe à la
moulinette d'un algorithme afin de
vérifier les relation mathématique qui
terrorise les techniques de mesure des
grandeurs économiques ce qu'on appelle
l'économétrie ses techniques n'ont cessé
de se développer depuis les années 1960
la scientificité de l'économie est
cependant une prétention fragile
maintenant quels sont les arguments
contre
le développement de l'économie réelle
n'a rien à voir avec la science
économique bien qu'on les enseignes
comme s'il s'agissait de mathématiques
les théories économiques n'ont jamais eu
la moindre utilité pratique a dit Karl
Popper
voici une blague d'économiste pourquoi
Dieu a-t-il créé les économistes pour
qu'on prenne les météorologues au
sérieux tout d'abord les fêtes des
mantes la fiabilité du savoir économique
on peut raisonner par l'absurde si
l'économie était bien une science au
même titre que les mathématiques ou que
la physique alors elle ne commettrait
pas d'erreur aussi énorme que celles qui
peuvent l'histoire économique notamment
à propos des crises par exemple 8 jours
avant l'effondrement de Wall Street en
octobre 1929 Irving Fisher été formel
pas de krach boursier en vue tu vas bien
ensuite elle est comme il n'a pas la
cohérence d'une science la réflexion
économique n'évolue pas dans un
paradigme au sens de Thomas Kuhn
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'existe pas unité de
pensée relativement stable autour d'un
cadre théorique conte sensuel au
contraire différentes écoles comme les
classiques et les keynésiens différentes
écoles sont en concurrence qui défendent
des lois contradictoire voir
incompatible
l'économie n'a jamais pu démontrer
l'existence de l'Oise économique a écrit
Jacques Sapir dans les trous noirs de la
science économique plus fondamentalement
enfin l'économie ne pourrai pas être une
science pourquoi donc parce que son
objet est l'activité humaine par
conséquent les expériences sur
lesquelles elle s'appuie ne peuvent être
reproduites en raison ne serait-ce que
de la variation dans le temps et dans
l'espace des préférences des individus
l'économiste française Jacques Sapir par
le des trous noirs de la science
économique
quels sont les branches de l'économie
qu'est-ce que la microéconomie et la
macroéconomie la différence tient
l'échelle d'analyse le préfixe micro
vient du grec Micro ce qui signifie
petit tandis que macro vient du grec
macro ce qui signifie grand la
microéconomie et tu dis donc le
comportement des acteurs individuelle
tel que le consommateur ou l'entreprise
ainsi que leurs interactions l'idée de
départ de ce courant et que l'individu
cherche à maximiser son utilité dans un
contexte en fonction de ses propres
ressources et de l'action des autres
acteurs
les micros économistes s'intéressent tu
as tout un tas de sujet de l'achat d'une
voiture d'occasion à la valeur des
diplômes en passant par les avantages du
mariage
la morale représente la façon dont les
gens aimeraient que le monde fonctionne
tandis que l'économie représente la
façon dont tu il fonctionne réellement a
écrit Stephen les 8 dents Freakonomics
la macroéconomie elle étudie les grands
agrégats économiques tel la production
l'investissement la consommation le taux
de chômage ou encore l'inflation les
médias par le beaucoup de ces grandeurs
parce qu'elle permet d'évaluer la
performance de l'économie d'un pays les
macros économistes peuvent mettre en
évidence la possibilité d'améliorer un
paramètre on en sacrifiant un autre par
exemple réduire le chômage en acceptant
une hausse des prix c'est John Maynard
Keynes qui dans la première moitié du
20e siècle à radicaliser la distinction
entre les deux échelles de l'analyse
économique il a repris par la la césure
qui apparaissent et alors entre la
mécanique quantique qui concerne à
l'infiniment petit et la mécanique
relativiste qui porte sur l'infiniment
grand
quelles sont les principales des écoles
en essayant d'être synthétique et
impartial c'est-à-dire en ne
disqualifiant pas les courant qui nous
déplaise je pense qu'on peut distinguer
3 écoles principal dans l'histoire de la
pensée économique tout d'abord l'école
classique apparaît en Europe au 18e
siècle c'est avec elle que commence
véritablement la science économique les
auteurs les plus emblématiques en sont
Adam Smith considéré comme le père de
l'économie et David Ricardo sur le plan
des idées c'est école libérale
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est plutôt
défavorable à l'intervention de l'État
dans l'économie
le libéralisme c'est le renard libre
dans le poulailler livre a dit Karl Marx
la deuxième école et c'est l'école
marxiste qui naît en Europe au milieu du
19e siècle à partir de l' œuvre de Karl
Marx elle se définit par opposition à
l'école classique qu'elle disqualifie
comme une idéologie bourgeoise servante
à justifier l'exploitation des classes
laborieuses
sur le plan des idées c'était colle
anticapitaliste parce qu'elle considère
que la propriété privée du capital
surtout les machines à l'époque elle
considère que la propriété privée du
capital est un principe injuste qui
maintient et développe l'inégalité et
donc le malheur du grand nombre dans la
société
la troisième et dernière école l'école
keynésienne est la fille dans un livre
publié en 1936 la théorie générale de
l'emploi de l'intérêt et de la monnaie
de Keynes cet auteur s'oppose lui aussi
à l'école classique mais sans remettre
en cause du capitalisme sont idées
fondamentales et que l'activité
économique est instable à court terme en
vertu de quoi l'État a la responsabilité
d'intervenir afin de réduire les effets
de court terme d'une crise sur le
bien-être de la population
à long terme nous serons tous morts les
économistes se fixe une tâche plus utile
s'ils peuvent seulement nous dire que
lorsque l'orage sera passé le séance
sera plat à nouveau a écrit 15 je vous
expliquerai plus en détail les idées des
3 écoles dans la suite du module et vous
verrez aussi qu'il existe beaucoup
d'autres courant
quels sont les sous discipline de
l'économie la liste est longue
potentiellement interminable parce qu'on
peut mettre beaucoup de choses après le
mot économie je vais donc nominé et
celle que vous devez connaître en
priorité pour votre culture générale les
sous discipline est plus importante sont
l'économie publique qui étudie les
politiques un état peut mener afin de
favoriser le développement économique et
le bien-être de sa population l'économie
monétaire qui étudie l'influence de la
monnaie sur l'activité économique et
l'économie du développement qui étudie
les déterminants de la pauvreté ainsi
que les moyens d'en sortir l'économie
international qui étudie les rapports
économique commerciaux financier et
monétaire entre différents pays
l'économie comportementale qui étudie
les comportement des individus dans des
situations économique et enfin
l'économie des organisations qui étudie
l'influence de l'organisation sur
l'activité économique
qui sont les économistes
comment devient-on économiste comme dans
la plupart des disciplines la prétention
scientifique le statut d'économistes
repose sur l'obtention d'un diplôme
généralement un doctorat est sur la
publication d'articles dans des revues
scientifiques la grande majorité des
universités des grandes écoles on est un
département d'économie ainsi que la
capacité à délivrer des diplômes en
économie cependant le titre d'économie
ce n'est pas protégé contrairement à
celui de médecin par exemple et certains
économistes mondialement reconnu n'ont
pas de diplôme dans la discipline à
l'instar de psychologue Daniel kaneman
qui apporte en plus le prix Nobel
d'économie en 2002 c'est donc la
reconnaissance des pères qui importe
les universités les plus réputées au
monde pour l'économie sont tout aux
États-Unis Harvard et le MIT dans
l'agglomération de boston Standford et
Berkeley en Californie ou encore à
l'université de Chicago très influent
depuis les années 1980 en Europe on peut
aussi si tu es là elle est ce pour
London School of Economics et en France
la TSE pour Toulouse School avec un
homme X ou officie Jean Tirole le prix
Nobel de 2014
les revues les plus réputés
international sont ce qu'on appelle le
top five
l'American économique review
économétrique à Le Journal of political
economy le journal avec un X et enfin le
with you have economics Thalys qu'est-ce
que le métier d'économiste pour exercer
le métier les économies sont plusieurs
options enseigner dans une université
comme Thomas Piketty à l'EHESS ou une
école de commerce comme Jean-Marc Daniel
a le SCP travailler dans un film tank
comme Maxime Bailly à génération libre
travailler dans une institution
financière une banque une compagnie
d'assurance comme Patrick Artus à
Natixis et enfin travailler dans un
organisme international tel le FMI ou la
Banque mondiale comme Benoît que EREA la
BCE de 2002 à 2019
en France on peut distinguer 3 profils
d'économistes premier profil les
universitaires former et enseignant à
l'université qui ont une approche plus
littéraire que les économistes de
réputation mondiale deuxième profil les
praticiens de l'économie des hauts
fonctionnaires passer par Léna et
l'inspection des finances comme Emmanuel
Macron souvent sans diplôme est
spécifiquement économique ni lien avec
le monde académique et qui met en place
la politique économique de la France 3e
et dernier profil les mathématiciens de
l'économie généralement issus des écoles
d'ingénieurs le Graal étant
Polytechnique ou l'École normale
supérieure est diplômé de Lindsay
aujourd'hui un économiste et aussi un
intellectuel il intervient volontiers
dans le débat public et l'autorité
récentes de cette ici Pline donne du
poids à son discours en apparence
dépourvu d'idéologie en écrivant des
livres verts en prenant la parole à la
télévision ils aident les gens à
comprendre le monde dans lequel ils
vivent certains économistes comme
Jacques Sapir ou Jean-Marc Daniel
jouissent par ailleurs d'une grande
culture générale
pour Friedrich Hayek prix Nobel 1974 un
économiste doit être un intellectuel
polyvalent personne ne serai peut-être
un grand économiste en étant seulement
économistes et je suis même tenté
d'ajouter qu'un économiste kinek
économiste peut devenir une gêne si ce
n'est un danger depuis 1969 l'Académie
royale des sciences de Suède remets
chaque année en octobre un prix Nobel
d'économie même si l'authenticité du
prix et contester la discipline
n'apparaît pas dans le testament Alfred
Nobel et même si les choix de l'Académie
suicide parfois la controverse il s'agit
tout de même d'une des récompenses les
plus prestigieuses de la discipline et
elle fait gagner 900000 € récipiendaire
4 Français l'ont déjà obtenu Gérard de
breux en 1983 Maurice Allais en 1988
Jean Tirole en 2014 et Esther Duflo en
alors à la vidéo vous a plu j'espère que
oui je vous rappelle que c'est un
extrait de ma formation culture générale
culture exprès si vous les en savoir
plus cliquer sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant on a droit de les vidéos ou
bien sûr celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo voilà voilà
comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à
m'écrire dans les commentaires et puis
surtout n'oubliez pas que vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
vous cultiver